[Music]
watch so much fun with friends on a
garage it's all that fun again on
chicken watch chicken watch ticking
watch okay
we were eating some Nashville hot
chicken in my chest it's in my head
[ __ ] it stop talking food I feel like
my into my ears I'll say I feels like
your scalp is connect and it burns a
little bounce up and then find it what
is that I would say as well yeah resume
read more Fried Chicken we are exploring
you wonderful Tokyo fried chicken
today we're going all the way to Japan
we're going to get box look at the
[ __ ] smog over there look at that is
Mountain no no in front of the mountain
all right we're here at Tokyo Fried
Chicken and Mia is joining us
chicken watts yeah is half Japanese so
she's joining us I thought let's bring
somebody who maybe is closer to the
culture to help us judge it
have you eaten a lot of Japanese food I
have I love karaage it's definitely my
favorite fried chicken that's a good
idea so it's not just some white dopes
always a strong idea you know to get
more opinions than just the white man
yeah but I first think she's not wearing
maroon yeah no I didn't get the memo
yeah dinosaurs though right this one
ever likes dinosaurs seats boys club and
boys club boys club only girls can have
dinosaurs that's traumatic transition
[Music]
good about took your Fried Chicken we
actually do this Japanese style
technique fully applied to Southern
Fried Chicken we marinate it overnight
in soy ginger and garlic a lot of other
fried chickens they concentrate the
flavor on the outside but with Japanese
fried chicken since it's marinated in
tastes of the flavor all the way down to
the meat of the chicken don't judge a
book by it's cover
that's a superficial flavor here does
the book how juicy it is before we serve
it we actually seasoned in our husband
and what's the house seasoning or is a
secret I can't tell you that chicken has
the most secret secret secrets are five
when they are served to everyone
watch and it's a low-key show we eat is
a chicken from Tokyo under Tokyo
that's where we wanna go
yeah take one we're gonna batter it now
and then we're gonna dredge it so you
are you a dredger you dunker you can
dunk sincere in place and all credit I'm
also tall taller people are better
Duncan okay yeah okay so go that way
it's red that's a grippy wing boom we
marinate overnight and each dredge it
batter it and then fry it up pretty good
this is kind of like natural I'm like a
little bit of a dredger now dredging it
I'm judging it I'm dredging it good I'm
dredging good I'm graduating good
Jackie coverage is pretty teacher
and idea time for you to learn to fry
I've never been this close to a deep
fryer before drop the bud okay the skin
okay you want to drop it outwards they
don't burn yourself wow that was
beautiful
how do you not burn yourself oh I burned
myself old [ __ ] sure after we fry it we
let her rest a little bit and then we
fry it again when you bite into the
chicken I mean nice and light and crispy
crispy like like that
I got doing the snapped that crispy like
leaves a new your foot like tempura I'm
imagining a lot of tempura vibes yeah
yeah on a scale from cockatoos to
tempura it's more closer than two to
take apart okay different ticking watch
ticking watch Jinyu watch you watch eyes
oh let's say how's it going do a chicken
watch with us and be on our chicken
watch episode
so rubric we're going for that crispness
that moisture now we learned about the
salinity recently which is the salt the
sort of like spice bath that you're
experiencing as always we had a WOW
factor it's not a really know much about
sake of fried chicken all I know is that
I see it on Facebook all the time it's
suggested to me but it's all the way out
so do you get targeted ads for Fried
Chicken on Facebook yeah so tell me
what's going on with this glove okay so
just in case you don't want your hand to
get too greasy to put the glove on your
non-dominant hand and your other hand
can hold the chopsticks do you always
keep chicken in this hand you could okay
thank you so much for all this this is
incredible
okay we're gonna eat all of it thank you
excited
mia has a little secret I do
[Music]
Kamiya would you tell us all your little
secret so I've eaten a lot of fried
chicken however for the last year and a
half I've been vegetarian
I've been thinking about adding chicken
back into my diet cuz I miss it so much
and so this is like my entry back into
the meat-eating world
oh my god I you do for excited too she
can watch oh my gosh this is huge
difference huge Wow you're gonna have
chicken for the first time in a year and
a half
yes I think you should take the
inaugural bite alright it's gonna be
like a slow-motion shot because no it's
not okay should i okay because it's hard
to switch the camera you can do it in
slow motion
Wow : it's so garlicky and salty yeah
you guys can't wait you've got it you
got it at the end it's not like Dorito
dust but how does that kind of a feeling
in your mouth
yeah the crunch is the first thing that
is like different about this stick in
its white crispy it's like a potato
chips there's something cleaner about it
I don't know why throw more healthy oil
with oil one thing that makes them
Japanese fried chicken really different
we fry it we use rice bran oil rice bran
oil rice brown boil rice bran oil yeah
boy yeah it's from the husk of the rice
it's we didn't know the rice had a husk
so it is more healthy a little ginger
e.classname
I like that this really feels like a
southern meal mm-hmm and it's but the
flavors are just all crazy yeah yeah the
flavors of our chicken or what our chef
grew up with and this is the type of
chicken that he'd like everyone to
experience I'm gonna hit with a little
ponzu yeah I'm not the spicy or the norm
spicy and you'll taste soy you'll taste
the ginger garlic Wow
this sweet ponzu makes it sweeter and
richer yeah that's like such a new depth
to it I got a little squirt of that
there as well
throw right in there oh yeah that's nice
oh look at that
in your face honey pons is here chicken
watch what's your name Jennifer can we
sit on your picnic
chicken watch this reminds me of getting
together with my family on New Year's we
tell each other what we're thankful for
and I am thankful for good friends and
delicious food hmm sometimes it tastes
good fried chicken we realize just how
lucky you are so true
[Music]
[Applause]
in the Train mercy
[Music]
chickens shot in the back of which
somebody put a flag and there will be
more but my internet is lag and Tamia hi
me yeah so ultimately our show is about
finding the best fried chicken in the
world do you think this is the best
fried chicken in the world and if not
what do you think about this chicken is
the best there's a lot different fried
chickens like he said everyone has their
own favorite but what I could say is
that the best parts about it I that it's
super juicy and linguistic great answer
fried chicken people are good people
yeah you know so do you guys think that
this might be the best fried chicken in
the world yeah I'm ready to say that
this is the most unique fried chicken
I've had and I really love that it
combines something new with something
about familiar with which is southern
fried chicken this is definitely a
chicken I'd bring home to my mother has
is the mom test you know that the mom
factor is the upside down version of the
wow factor
do you think you're gonna continue on
your chicken train yeah I think I'm only
gonna come here though I don't know how
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
chickens eating